[Music]
you guys are amazing thank you so much
Brie from yo you're from San Jose okay
cool but you are Korean that's why you
exactly it's there's this thing yeah
when I was in Korea it was absolutely
amazing that people were amazing and all
the girls would be like I want a selfie
but before they would get the selfie
they go they do this they cover their
mouths they go and then I would say do
you want to get a selfie do you really
want to stop and then we got to take a
selfie that go okay which ones to renew
you it's so crazy you guys are an
absolutely incredible audience I don't
know why you're holding a teddy bear in
the back but it looks threatening okay
what have you done to the bear what's
that it's the masturbating bears son
very nice that's a character you said on
the show the masturbating bear and then
I realized I was too old to have a
character like that on my show I have
children now it's very nice of you to
make that yes I like to taking up I like
me you took a curtsy after the
masturbating bear reference you guys an
amazing audience come on back sometime
[Applause]
[Music]
you